perhaps the only thing more bizarre than
a massive network of lakes rivers and
even a dense forest the size of Texas in
the middle of the Sahara Desert along
with numerous cities settlements and
even castles blanketing virtually the
entire region of the Sahara is the
realization that these lost 600 year old
Maps literally annotate these geological
features several thousand years prior to
their modern scientific discovery how
could they have possibly have known of
the existence of the green Sahara 5 000
years before us but perhaps the only
thing Stranger Than That is the fact
that one of the first ever maps of the
African continent seemingly shows a
giant white naked one-eyed cyclops in
the middle of what is in modern day
Nigeria and Cameroon my name is Jimmy
corsetti subscribe to the bright Insight
YouTube channel to see my latest video
on this unbelievably thought-provoking
topic